let's look at another outrageous event
where carrie lake claimed that donald
trump and ron desantis have large
penises this is the place where we are
now in american right-wing politics
these people are listen i i have no
issue
with people work comedians working blue
i have no uh prudish tendencies when it
comes to
any of this sort of stuff
it's just that it's pathetic that this
is what your movement is reduced to
trump now getting applause
when he swears he'll drop an s-bomb or
an f-bomb during some of his uh speeches
and the crap the crowd which is
otherwise almost comatose from trump's
boring stories will get riled up when
trump swears and similarly this is
carrie lake she's the republican nominee
for the arizona gubernatorial race she
won her uh primary a week or two ago
she shows up
and first of all interestingly not
taking sides between trump and desantis
which is a growing element of civil war
within the republican party and she says
she can just tell from their energy
trump's got a large penis and desantis
has one too it
i can't believe this is what's happening
sick
he is gutsy
the guy has bigger
okay
[Applause]
wait let me think about how i want to
word this my staff always says whatever
you do do not say balls
remember carrie lake is a pro-family
christian
god-fearing candidate this is who the
evangelical's like
so i'm not going to say it
that guy
[Music]
has a backbone made of steel
i'll tell you what he's got i don't know
if you heard of this but he's got bde
anybody know what that means
ask your kids about it later
i call it big
desantis energy
right
he's got the same kind of bde that
president trump has
so carrie lake very impressed with the
large penis energy
of both trump and desantis and i guess
that's the new christian talking point
it's not who can pretend to be the most
religious it's who can take credit for
the largest genitals the these people
are just deranged it it's they are a
parody of themselves this was by the way
at all over the weekend at a turning
point usa event in phoenix arizona
and um
it it was just riddled with lies all the
way down
a new one ass i could play anything i
played would be filled with lies but one
other aspect speaking of ron desantis
ron desantis showed up and during his
speech he of course condemned the search
warrant being executed at donald trump's
mar-a-lago
but he wrongly claimed that the fbi has
gone after parents at school board
meetings now that hasn't happened i'll
tell you where he's getting this but
listen to this lie from ron desantis i
remember the fbi at merrick garland's
direction
being sicked on parents
going to school board meetings
meanwhile when you have a law that
protects supreme court justices is the
fbi out there protecting our
conservative justices no
when you have violations of law where
people are targeting cr pregnancy crisis
centers are they doing their job and
enforcing the law there no
they're enforcing the law based on who
they like and who they don't like
that is not a republic
well maybe it's a banana republic when
that okay so what on earth is desantis
talking about he says merrick garland
sicked the fbi on parents at school
board meetings and my challenge to you
is to name a single parent that the fbi
arrested and or charged with anything
for going to a school board meeting
that's not what happened what happened
was that there was a memo released which
said
some of these parents
who are showing up at school board
meetings might be making terroristic
threats when parents show up at school
board meetings and threaten all sorts of
different things because of a vaccine
policy or a mask policy or whatever
the doj said consider whether some of
those threats to show up and remember
some of them said i'm going to show up
on monday with guns at the school
the doj correctly said evaluate whether
that counts as a terroristic threat
and it makes absolutely perfect sense
what ron desantis says happened didn't
happen the fbi was not sicked on any
individual parents and none of them were
actually arrested or charged so lies all
the way down of course it is a turning
point usa event and the truth is this is
this is not going to stop this stuff is
going to continue and we just have to
have a bigger fire hose of truth
to overwhelm their fire hose of lies
that's really the only thing i can think
of that would help us actually deal with
this we're going to take a quick break
we'll have these clips on our facebook
you can find us on facebook at
facebook.com david pakman show after the
break we will hear from
some republicans uh their views just
random average republicans their views
on what's going on
and we will also see an incredible
exchange on news max
between the former national security
adviser john bolton and newsmax host
eric balling on the subject of foreign
policy stay tuned this is absolutely
incredible video
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality
vitamins and minerals and my probiotics
and it's all from whole food sources i
drink it in the morning i know i'm good
i don't have to be messing around with
different pills and supplements or
whatever or spend time planning when
what time of day do i need to take each
one i just get it all with one scoop you
can put it in a smoothie you can drink
it straight it tastes great and then i'm
just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below